these are the best tools that we have
and
when we measure it we get an answer
that's somewhat different and the size
of this tension or significance of the
difference has grown over 10 years
pretty steadily so that we've reached
you know more than five Sigma and
through duplication of measurements
other people have done with other
techniques what has shown up is a funny
dichotomy that how fast the universe is
expanding seems to depend on whether you
start from the beginning shortly after
the big bang or whether you start from
the present and you know a story
shouldn't depend on which end of the
story you started that's how it looks to
us and so that's why a lot of people are
suspecting maybe it's the cosmological
model itself the story We Tell ourselves
to connect the beginning and end
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to another exciting
episode of the into the impossible
podcast
featuring a friend an inspiration a
local hero and a global Cosmic hero one
of the few people on Earth who proved
Einstein wrong and demonstrated that he
actually made a blunder by calling his
blunder a blunder we'll get into that
it's my friend Adam Reese Professor
Bloomberg professor at the Johns Hopkins
University which I understand is not a
plural but it's a singular name Jones
and uh Adam is the Bloomberg Professor
he's also known for uh third place in
the Charlie Town Symposium in 2005 which
uh we we can we can get into some
information there I there's a person
that that won that who was supposed to
go on to great things in life including
potentially winning Nobel Prize won't
speak about him that's me uh we will
speak about the person that uh that did
eventually achieve this this great
stupendous feat and uh that's Adam Reese
of course so Adam as you know when we
have guests on the podcast that have
written books we always have a segment
called judging books by their covers in
this case we uh we don't have a book by
by you I'm hoping to be your agent and
get residuals but we have a paper that's
signed by you and it is called well I'll
let you go through it but we always ask
what is the Genesis of the title how did
you come up with it what was that
process like and usually the authors
come and say my publicist or publisher
told me how to do it this way yeah but
in this case I assume you had some input
on it and uh and you'll have uh
something to say about it as well as the
cover illustration which isn't really
here but we'll talk about let's talk
about figure one okay so Adam Reese
judge the paper by its cover and its
title and its and its artwork please
uh okay well you know we decided to call
this one
observational evidence from supernovae
for an accelerating universe and a cause
module constant and uh this was a case
where we decided to say the whole story
in the title in case you never got past
the title or even read the abstract
um but no this was uh this was our
Discovery paper uh we had observed
distant type 1A supernovae we were using
them as tools for measuring distances
also for measuring redshift so together
the two measure the expansion rate of
the universe we had measured nearby ones
which told us the expansion rate today
we were looking at distant ones to tell
us the expansion rate in the past we
were testing the COS module expectation
that the expansion since the Big Bang
was slowing down uh and instead we saw
that it was speeding up that it was
accelerating and so that's why it's the
first statement and why is that uh to be
totally honest we don't really know for
sure this is generally given the name
Dark Energy but a specific kind of dark
energy the one with the greatest history
and also the one that's the simplest and
sort of mathematically is Einstein's
cause module constant and so in that
title we said we see the universe
accelerating it kind of looks like a
horizontal constant
and we'll get in some of the details of
what a cosmological constant is in just
a bit but um suffice it to say as I
mentioned that good old Albert here he
had originally put in a cosmological
constant because as we teach our
students he knew that he was made of
matter and anything that has a universe
that has matter can either contract or
expand but it can't be static and back
then I used to make fun of him say oh
you know how could he put this in it's
so stupid but really back in 1915 1917
the universe was the Milky Way right
correct so what he did was not that
unexpected even until 1929 when he
recanted so to speak which was after the
night after he won his Nobel Prize
himself in 1922 do you know why he
received it in 22 I he won the 21 Nobel
Prize and he received it in 22. really I
remember it took him a while to get the
message and it took him a while to get
there yeah
um but I also know there was a lot of
controversy about giving him the Nobel
Prize even though you know he should
have won five of them exactly right but
going back to uh his motivation uh I
mean the the lore is that he had asked
astronomers of the day what's the
universe which you said is the Milky Way
what's it doing and they said it isn't
moving all that much you know the
velocities of stars was relatively small
and so he took that to mean the universe
was static more or less so that was a
kind of observational constraint
um you know the story could have been
quite different if uh you know he had
asked them I don't know 10 years later
and uh learned that actually the the
Galaxies have red chips and things are
moving apart so you know he got bad
information and so he kind of made his
theory fit that yeah and that's it's
really hard to get back in the mindset
of somebody first of all in the in the
early 90s before you and your teammate
and your competitors we'll get into that
in some some detail I hope
um and uh you know that that was it made
sense events and actually even Hubble's
early data were you know horrendously
noisy and he was relying on Henrietta
Levitt's data and and vesto slight I
love the name vesto I was going to name
one of my kids yeah you know I mean it's
not on the top list these days it's not
yeah it hasn't made the list at a while
I get teased a bit at school
it sounds like Vespa I don't know it
could be could be kind of a cool thing
um but nowadays you know we talk about
the cosmological constant we're even
trying to measure is it varying is it is
it dark energy or is it a constant and
uh and we just accept that there's some
form of repulsive anti-gravitational
Force causing galaxies to expand but
what was it like as an early graduate
student in the 90s working at Harvard
Bob kirschner you know a friend of the
show and and so forth uh Brian Schmidt
passed guest on the show
um what was it like when when you were
you know dealing with this milieu you
had this expectation the universe was
dominated by matter it's all we knew
about there's there but it didn't seem
like we lived in an open universe and
what was it like to operate that
framework and have the realization that
there's something really funny going on
in the cosmos right well you know I
would like to tell you glorious things
about deep thoughts that you know we had
or that I had at the time but you know
to be honest you're doing a measurement
an experiment that's hard that people
haven't done before and you just want to
get the right answer you know that's all
you're just kind of obsessed with
getting it right and not screwing it up
and so the reality is when we saw that
result my thought was uh we screwed this
up you know and then you have to go
through a lot of checks and yet you know
you've also learned to avoid
confirmation bias which means that you
know you don't want to just uh assume
you made a mistake and and the first
time you see anything sort of go yeah
okay that's got to be a mistake or
something you really need to get it
right and so you know we went through a
process of checking things you know
anytime you make a measurement there are
certain aspects of the experiment that
you're a little uncomfortable with you
think oh that's the first thing I'm
going to go take a look at so you know
there was this obscure thing astronomers
called K Corrections which is really
just a fancy term for relativistic
Corrections uh you know the fact that
we're looking at things with larger
redshifts and so redshift has many
effects it or I should say expansion as
many effects it causes redshift it
causes time dilation it changes the
energy density of uh photons that you're
looking at there's I think five terms
altogether and you've got to get them
all right so usually it's like oh do we
leave out one of the one plus Z terms or
did we stick in one too many and uh so
you know you go back over the whole
process when you get an answer that you
don't expect
and and now we have that similar
situation where we we see strange things
although I would classify your Discovery
as an argue in my first book is a
serendipitous Discovery because you were
looking for the opposite so that is sort
of self-insulating against confirmation
bias like Penzeys and Wilson we were
talking about before we start recording
they weren't looking for the CMB in fact
you know they were trying to get rid of
some noise with the observations the
first Telecommunications and satellite
so they they would have preferred
probably originally that it wasn't there
in the first place now we're in the
situation where astronomers are and
physicists are trying to explain the
so-called Hubble tension and uh you know
I can't resist I had on you know this
this famous Theory Of Consciousness
individual named David Chalmers at NYU
who's known for What's called the hard
problem of Consciousness uh which is you
know can you really identify and Define
what the conscious qualia experiences of
another I had him on I was like look and
he's from Australia so I said look if I
had on um uh you know someone from
Sweden and uh and I don't know if I have
an ABBA and I don't ask them to play you
know dancing queen or something like
that or if I had an AC DC because he's
Australian I said got to play back come
on you got to play it uh so can you
please describe this is like you're like
you're you're playing the role of ABBA
here okay AC DC okay four-letter
acronyms okay cool tell me what is the
Hubble tension and could we be in sort
of the opposite domain or look or
everyone's posing Solutions unlike the
purity of your Discovery and your
colleagues right well so the Hubble
tension let me just back up the Hubble
constant is the rate at which the
universe expands today
um and
if we understand the universe very well
we should be able to translate the rate
at which the universe expands at any
time in the universe to any other time
that's sort of in a way the idea of
physics you know you throw a ball in the
air and you know if you know how fast
the ball is traveling at some point
you'll know how fast the ball is
traveling at all points so observations
of the cosmic microwave background which
of course you work on give us a very
detailed picture of the universe shortly
after the big bang but you know that was
a long time ago you know some you know
more than 13 billion years ago uh told
us very specifically what the universe
looked like then and so using the
physics of the universe we should be
able to translate that information to
how fast the universe is expanding today
I would call this a prediction but it's
a very precise prediction and so a
powerful you know I've been calling it
an end-to-end test of our understanding
of the universe is to measure how fast
the universe is expanding using the best
tools that we have and so for you know
the last 15 years we've been doing that
making more and more precise
measurements using the Hubble Space
Telescope using Gaia European Space
Agency Mission measuring parallaxes Now
using the James Webb Space Telescope so
these are uh you know these are the best
tools that we have and
when we measure it we get an answer
that's somewhat different and the size
of this tension or significance of the
difference has grown over 10 years
pretty steadily so that we've reached
you know more than five Sigma different
so
five times the size of the mutual error
bars and so that's usually the point in
time where physicists scientists are
willing to check off being unlucky as a
possible answer and so we I think have
more or less checked that off
um and through duplication of
measurements other people have done with
other techniques uh what has shown up is
a funny dichotomy that how fast the
universe is expanding seems to depend on
whether you start from the beginning uh
shortly after the big bang or whether
you start from the present uh and you
know a story shouldn't depend on which
end of the story you start in but that's
how it looks to us and so that's why a
lot of people are suspecting maybe it's
the cosmological model itself the story
We Tell ourselves to connect the
beginning and end so of course the
Hubble constant is the current time
evaluation of the time derivative of the
scale factor divided by the scale factor
itself evaluated today I always tell my
students you know the Hubble you know
the Hubble parameter is the second most
important number in all of cosmology if
you had just one choice though I'd say
take a of T take the scale factor from
which you can get everything either
kinematically or otherwise
um but I can't resist because you're
here and and because my students you
know and I asked them well like the
first derivative of the scale factor is
the Hubble constant it's proportional to
Apple parameter the second derivative is
the Q naught deceleration parameter
which you thought would be decelerating
back in the 90s and it's even named the
deceleration parameter the expectation
is built right into the name
maybe it's true because at the very
early times it was deceptional but then
uh the third derivative I asked my my
students I was like I can't remember
when they said jerk jerk I was like how
dare you how dare you call me a jerk
um what could we learn if anything from
the third derivative I was thinking you
can write down the third derivative of
Newtonian mechanics of a particle just
moving around and maybe it has a rate of
change of acceleration but what
physically would it correspond to it
would it lead to another parameter could
it could it tell us about a resolution
of the Hubble tension could it tell us
about Dark Energy in some way or what
could it tell us if we could measure hey
friends just a quick request while
you're enjoying this video to leave a
thumbs up my thumb's a little bit
preoccupied with all Carl Sagan over
here but I hope yours is free enough to
leave a like it really helps me with the
algorithm and for extra credit homework
assignment leave a comment down below
what you're enjoying about this video
now back to the show I mean so in
principle it's the transition uh that we
see between the universe decelerating
and accelerating
um you know it's very surprising that
there is a transition that we can
witness in our you know recent Cosmic
history I mean it's very hard to
understand because you know if it's a
cosmological constant Dark Energy the
universe will just continue this way for
trillions of years so the transition was
quite recent this is called the why now
problem but going back to the cosmic
jerk um you know it's possible different
conceptualizations of what Dark Energy
could be could give you different values
for the jerk the cosmodical constant uh
is tells us that it should be one in
kind of dimensionless units
um so I think it's another one of these
you know fundamental tests that you need
to do when anytime you you have a theory
that you're not you know totally
confident in maybe it's phenomenological
if it tells you something you should see
you should go look at that right you
know you should measure it as best as
you can and so you know I would just put
this on that list of things that you
know you should check uh there could be
a surprise this is you know how we test
theories did it ever you and I were
talking over dinner last night about you
know the different types of scientists
you know some are more Curious some
treat what we do as cosmologists is you
know work a day you know they they pack
their lunch bucket every day and come to
work and uh and so forth but others
think contemplate the deepest possible
topics and and Concepts and and all of
in all of science you know I pointed out
to my students on the first day of
cosmology
um if you go to Wikipedia and you type
in science the first image that comes up
is a picture from the wmap team and the
famous you know evolution of the
universe is seen from you know some
God's eye perspective if you will so
that means that it's sort of
paradigmatic
um and a huge swath of the phase space
of the universe's history is that
Afflicted and affected by dark energy
um do you ever stop and and think about
it uh I know we're you know we're kind
of you're an MIT grad you guys are you
know very very serious do you ever think
what are the implications of this I mean
as you said trillions of years of
evolution why here why now
um does it ever overwhelm you just as a
human being does it ever like affect you
that wow I'm in the same kind of
category of people that first knew some
fundamental truth about the universe and
hasn't affected you just as a human
being as a parent right Etc
um I feel like it's the awe that I get
thinking about the universe is very
closely connected to the same awe I felt
as a kid just looking up into the sky
you know just looking up at the stars
and the Blackness and thinking about you
know how far away things are and you
know my parents telling me things that
you see are millions of light years away
that means that the light is reaching
from millions of years ago I remember my
dad telling me you know some of those
Stars might not even be there anymore
that you're seeing and I was just trying
to picture what does that mean like
there's some beam of light it's headed
to me and it doesn't have a back end to
it anymore that's so crazy and you know
so I would say the awe that I feel is
the same awe that other people
experience who have really looked up at
space and have had that feeling and I'll
admit there are people who don't look up
who are you know not so fascinated by
that this is I sort of divide the world
into some people are curious and some
people are not curious you can almost
divide people up and the people who are
not curious It's hard to describe to him
curiosity and the people who are curious
experience all like that you know on a
fairly regular basis and so you know I
just consider myself lucky that I get to
combine the work that I do with that
curious awe feeling so a lot of times we
kind of devolve on this podcast into you
know religious or theological topics
we're not going to get too religious or
theological but there's a series of
essays written by Rabbi Jonathan sacks
who is the chief Rabbi of the British
Commonwealth until he died sadly a
couple years ago way too early and he
used to talk about
um so-called Peak experiences which is a
concept from psychology that when you
have when you see the Grand Canyon when
you see a sunset when you see this yeah
um people have awe and they want to have
uh some sort of gratitude to displace
that feeling of awe towards or project
towards a source of gratitude obviously
for a rabbi he's talking about God and
some Almighty power it could be nature
it could be whatever uh you like but
humans love to have some sort of Prima
fascia move over that that causes them
to experience the feeling of gratitude I
believe that as scientists we become
inured to such feelings because we
witness it every day when you start
thinking about well if like one of these
parameters was changed by attacking a
little bit we wouldn't be here wondering
why does it have the value that it has I
wonder you know is there any way that
you can cultivate you know you have
children I have children can we
cultivate the maintenance not just the
incipient the original curiosity all
kids have right but how do you sustain
it because you're right like some of my
colleagues In This Very building I won't
say who you know I'll say like I'll have
them over for dinner whatever I'll look
at a constellation and I'll say oh what
do you what do you make of that
Constellation Are you I don't know what
that is right and I always joke like oh
yeah if you study geography I wouldn't
expect you to know where Mexico is you
know it's just it's just your freaking
job your Astro Namer but but tell me is
there a way to to you know to inculcate
but also to maintain sustain or is it
really innate in the human being you
know individually I mean I think you
know anytime you spend a lot of time
looking at one thing even if it was
something that gave you awe you know
even if you're the you know tour guide
of the Grand Canyon you know at some
point you know you you get used to it a
little bit so that you're not like each
day like oh my God look at that right
I'm sorry to interrupt you but uh every
um uh every so often I take one of my
kids you know I pretend I'm a good dad I
take them on a field trip and there was
a field trip about three or four years
ago before covet at Sea World here in
lovely San Diego come and visit lovely
downtown San Diego you'll get a
commission you got a free signed copy of
that I'm sorry and I got there 15
minutes early I'm good dad and I was a
chaperone and uh there's a huge roller
coaster there I forget the name of it
Stuart I don't know if you know the name
of it but let me know what it's called
the lightning or whatever so there's
some huge roller coaster and there's a
guy whose job it is to go on the roller
coaster by himself every morning and
make sure
he's not gonna die and I and I always
bring my telescopes and binoculars
wherever I go as I'm sure you do and I
like zoomed in on him and the guy was
like
he was like almost like Angry
totally oblivious to so you're right
yeah the short guy with the Grand Canyon
it's a great analogy and you know I
would say in my example in particular
um you know I've been looking at images
from the Hubble Space Telescope for
about 20 years yeah right and I I know
conceptually intellectually that they
are fantastic but I am so used to what
they're should look like that
occasionally I'll get one and I'll be
like they're a little that one's a
little out of focus I think that one's
not it's not so sharp and so I got to
experience all over again uh this past
year when we launched the James Webb
Space Telescope and I'm now looking at
the same things that I've studied stared
at whatever with Hubble and Along Comes
James Webb and awe comes right back to
me uh in that experience I'm I'm now
looking at images from James Webb Space
Telescope and I have double law in that
you know I was really skeptical that
this thing was going to work and so it's
like you mean that thing actually worked
and you mean this is I could actually
see like this and so it's just
spectacular wow so getting those
experiences all it requires is a new 10
billion dollar telescope yeah everything
bigger Grand King in and we'll all be
right back I've heard that the Mariner
trench on Mars is quite nice so let's
talk about their web paper I read it uh
earlier today and I'm you know I can
really say it because I'm a cosmologist
so what the hell do I know about cepheid
variables but I was was really
interested to read this paper first of
all you're an excellent writer you know
that that's why I want to be and get the
royalties and residuals from your
upcoming books in perpetuity
um stay tuned for that announcement next
time Adam is in town just to be clear my
papers are free the the telescopes are
taxpayers work and we I don't that's
right this is free but the signed one
that'll cost you
um and and I should mention also that
you're here for to deliver the dash in
lecture which is a prize lecture that we
offer to the most renowned uh you know
physicists and cosmologists around the
world and astronomers and and you
following a grand tradition Barry barish
came a few years back and and we've had
uh Andrea Gaz and many other you know
luminaries both uh astronomical and
other ones
but I read this paper and uh with one of
your students from just this year
initial observations cepheid variables
and what was interesting and fascinating
to me is you were basically using it if
I'm not wrong to compare measurements
made from a supernova that's like your
father's light from a star that may not
appear it's from a supernova that popped
off in in the year 2012.
um talk about that what kind of
supernova is it what yeah what is that
and how do you use something it's gone
now how could web observe something
that's not right right right so you know
uh uh going back to the Greeks the
Greeks uh first taught us about
triangles which are very useful and they
taught us uh how to measure Parallax
which is you know something we do
naturally with our eyes which is to
build a triangle in space a virtual
triangle
um and if you can uh get to get a view
from two different spots on the triangle
right you can measure the angle through
which a distance object moves and that
completes the triangle that angle is the
you know enclosed angle if you can
measure what we call the Baseline the
separation between your two points of
view then you know basic trigonometry
tells you the length of that triangle
tells you the distance and so in an
Ideal World we would go out and we would
look at everything with using Parallax
and Anarchy's Parallax we obtained by uh
waiting six months for the earth to move
from one side of its orbit to the other
that makes our triangle the problem is
unfortunately that things are really far
away in the universe they're really
shockingly far away in fact if I could
just say this is one of the main reasons
in the beginning that the Greeks
disputed the idea that the Earth moved
around the Sun was because they reasoned
if that were the case then as they
looked out at distant things like stars
you know what we see as constellations
would change their shape over the course
of the year because you know we would
move and you know and so they couldn't
see any uh what we would call Parallax
and so they said therefore the Earth is
not moving and so what they just
couldn't imagine was just how far away
things are there was Parallax it was
just too small to see and so over the
years we've gotten much better at
measuring Parallax primarily with space
missions but even with the greatest
space mission which right now is Gaia
European Space Agency Mission we cannot
measure Parallax outside the Milky Way
okay so if we want to measure distances
even longer range we have to measure the
parallaxes of certain kinds of stars in
the Milky Way whose uh whose
characteristics allow us to recognize
them in other galaxies so that when we
see one we could say oh that's just like
this star nearby that I measured The
Parallax for it's just far away its
brightness will tell me how far away it
is and so there's a certain class of
star called a cepheid variable uh that
has been our gold standard of measuring
distances to galaxies since Henrietta
Swan Leavitt first recognized them in
the small magellanic Cloud more than a
hundred years ago so this is you know we
don't get the invention of new kinds of
stars all the time so we sort of you
know in many cases we use what was known
just with better technology and so the
wonderful thing about these cepheid
variables is first of all they're super
giant Stars not just regular Stars they
are among the most luminous stars that
exist and so that means that not only do
you have a standard candle but your
standard candle is a lighthouse it's
really powerful so we can measure really
long range distances and the other thing
that makes them very handy is they vary
in their brightness now that might sound
annoying like oh you told me you want to
stay in your kennel you want a variable
candle well no they're mean the average
brightness they have is the standard
candle but the fact that they vary and
the period that their variation occurs
over scales with the mass or Luminosity
of the star so that by measuring the
period we can actually tell just how
luminous that standard candle is so it
it customizes or standardizes the
measurement and so we find with cepheid
variables we can measure distances with
one star that are good to just like
three percent and so now what we do is
we use the Hubble Space Telescope to
measure the distance to galaxies with
cepheid variables but we pick special
galaxies we pick ones that recently
hosted a type 1A Supernova and the
reason is because cepheid variables will
only carry you so far tens of
megaparsecs type 1A supernovae which are
Chandra sakarma white dwarfs
are much more luminous than cepheid
variables they reach 5 billion solar
luminosities and so with powerful
telescopes we can see them all the way
out to redshift two maybe even Beyond
and so this forms what we call the
cosmic distance ladder the ability to
measure the Parallax to a kind of a star
to measure its Luminosity see that star
in a galaxy that hosted a type 1A
Supernova to calibrate it and then see
type 1A supernovae about as far as you
need to and so we use this to gauge the
expansion rate of the universe and how
well do we have to know I you know I
taught this obviously you know only a
fraction as well as you could uh convey
but you know it occurred to me that well
the cepheids are there you know it's a
nuclear power plant in space and we we
know very little about our own sun and
how much could individual intrinsic
variations which for the cognizant a
systematic variations uh in a cepheid
versus systematic variations in in white
dwarf stars or in these type 1A
Supernova where you know is there any
dependence on the on the companion to
the white dwarf so first of all white
dwarf is this weird material called
degenerate matter which when you add
more to it it gets smaller which is kind
of strange right it's nuclear matter
um it is the end point of what our sun
will get to I always forget it uh it
won't reach the chain or sacr mass no
not the shadow attacker but will it be a
white dwarf it will be a white dwarf
which is basically a carbon it's a pure
uh Diamond basically right but it's not
undergoing thermonuclear Fusion anymore
so it's just like a junk chunk of of um
of of this material so is it possible
that you know we could explain some of
the Hubble tension for nuclear physics
side but assume you're perfect
everything you do is perfect but could
we not understand either the uh you know
intrinsic properties of the nuclear
reactions going on a cepheid or in the
companion to a white dwarf or their
operations to explain the Hubble tension
right so
um observational cosmology sort of the
way at least I practice it is based on
empirical calibration of these tools so
we start out with Theory and we say oh
type 1A Supernova changer say car Mass
explosion okay that should be a pretty
good standard candle let me start there
or cepheid variable okay we understand
uh pulsations we understand the the
opacity mechanism that drives this we
understand that this ought to be a good
standard candle let me start there and
then we develop what we call training
sets which are basically large samples
where we know the answer where we know
what they should look like so for
example for cephate variables you might
look at a Galaxy that has many hundreds
of them and now you know they're
effectively all at the same distance
from us so now you look for empirical
characteristics that might change or
correlate with their indicating that
that Galaxy's a little too far A little
too close and so you train your your
measurements to sort of account for
those and so we've done that with type
1A supernovae that was something I
worked on in my thesis uh turns out the
light curve shape of the type 1A
Supernova tells you whether it's a
little more luminous or less luminous
the color tells you uh whether it's been
affected by dust or not you correct for
that the same thing with cepheid
variables we look at many of them in a
galaxy and we correlate uh the
metallicity of chemical abundance of the
cepheid variable with its Luminosity we
calibrate that out we make our
measurements in the near infrared to
avoid the effects of dust so there's no
step of sort of theoretical input where
we would say oh uh if uh some process in
the star convection or conduction is
occurring differently than we thought
that isn't actually what we do we do
this empirically but most importantly
it's purely differentially so we're
always comparing as I said we're
starting starting out with Parallax
that's where the distant knowledge comes
in that's the stable base correct and
then everything after that is ensuring
that the object that you're measuring at
one location where you measure Parallax
is the same as the object you're
measuring far away and so you measure
everything you can about it if you can
explain all of the dispersion the the
the scatter as understandable
experimental errors and if there's
nothing left over then you have a lot of
confidence there as well and so that's
you know that's more or less the process
and at some point at the end of the day
we have to rely on something we call the
cosmological principle which more or
less says that
we are not in a special place in the
universe there are no special places and
so uh once I've made measurements of
these properties there's no reason a
supernova or a cepheid variable should
be different than another one just
because it's in a different place in
space right because if we couldn't
assume that we'd have to sort of give up
on doing all experiments so instead we
say we'll assume that and then if
everything is crazy and nothing makes
sense we may revisit that but um you
know it's worked pretty well so far so
in this paper we're in the app J in 2023
with your student you talk about this
effect that you call like biasing bright
what does that refer to right is the
Hubble is the Hubble biased dim compared
to the web right first of all you're
using a specific package of
instrumentation on the web that's
different from the Hubble correct in a
far different wavelength region so what
does it mean that it's bias price should
we trust you at all right so
um you know in 1998 when we saw that the
Universe was accelerating right it's a
change of measurements but the new
measurement the thing that you know
hadn't been done before was looking at
distance supernovae and they were
fainter than you would have expected if
the universe wasn't accelerating so in
those days we thought is there a reason
Supernova could be fainter you know you
think in the direction of what seems
surprising in the present case we look
at the Hubble tension and one way to
look at it is to say oh the the cepheids
uh look
brighter in galaxies that host type 1A
supernovae then I would have expected if
there wasn't this Hubble tension so is
there a way I can understand that they
are brighter than they really are that
they just look brighter okay and so we
look for that with the James Webb Space
Telescope because James Webb has such
better resolution that you know maybe it
could have shown us if there was
something else kind of snuggled up to
the cepheid variable that was adding
light and biasing it bright and so with
the great resolution of the James Webb
Space Telescope and I'm going to talk
more about this in my talk today we have
reached the limit where we can really
see down to the background where there's
nothing else around and so far the
cepheid variables don't look any
different than they look like with the
Hubble Space Telescope now we're using a
much more powerful telescope much
greater sensitivity and you know this to
some people this might seem boring like
oh wow you do a measurement and then you
go out into another telescope and you
just do it again and it's like together
that's what we do because they have very
different systematics yeah they're very
different systematics it's hard to tell
a story that the uh uh you know the
effect wouldn't uh go away if you looked
with a telescope with a better
resolution or greater sensitivity or a
different wavelength or things like that
so you know the the real test of uh
experimental result is you know it
doesn't matter who's looking at it with
which telescope or what it's it's a
fundamental truth it's it's on the sky
um and so so far you know the the Hubble
tension seems to be passing that test
um so it's a that's persisting which is
which is you know on one hand it's it's
disappointing because you don't have a
resolution but I don't think it's really
inspiring because maybe you'll be the
person out there watching this that can
add to our knowledge and maybe resolve
it or maybe discover maybe there's
something we don't understand
intrinsically about gravity about
today's time about Lorenson Barons all
sorts of things and it's important I
think to point out to people you know
when cosmologists say oh we have a model
of the universe oh we understand the
universe you know you have to understand
that our what we call model really is a
description of the universe rather than
maybe a deep physical understanding of
and so you know we have dark energy we
don't understand the nature of that yet
uh we have dark matter you know it's we
think it's a particle we don't know the
properties of the particle we don't know
if it has collisions if it decays uh if
it's stable uh if it interacts and so we
take some very vanilla guesses about
that and so when we see tensions really
all we're saying is we see some
measurement that doesn't match the most
vanilla gas for our understanding of the
universe and so that might simply mean
that there's a wrinkle to our
understanding of the universe that
something is not totally vanilla it's
pistachio or something you know and so
you know it's it's you know sometimes I
think people get the idea like we're
upset or disturbed everything should fit
and we gotta you know get a hammer and
nail down this nail and and get
everything to stick and I would say just
the opposite I would say you know
tensions are our opportunities you know
the story of science always is you have
a paradigm you have a model you know uh
most models are useful but they're not
correct and so you use the model as a
tool to make predictions and then
eventually when your measurements get
good enough you break the model because
it's not good enough for that
measurement and then you learn something
so you know at worst I would say we're
going through that standard process that
is usually very enlightening yeah it's
like when they turn on the you know the
Large Hadron Collider they they first
calibrate and they discover all the
previous 70 Nobel prizes
um speaking of Nobel Prize you're kind
enough to to loan me your Nobel Prize
thank you so much for telling that
um
um I remember the day that you won it
because I was giving a colloquium on the
east coast and my alma mater at Brown
University
um and uh and I remember reading in the
newspaper a comment from your uh your
thesis advisor uh Bob kirschner and I
remember he was asked what's the
strongest force in the universe it's not
gravity it's jealousy I asked Brian
Schmidt this what did he mean what was
he talking about this what what do you
think I've never asked him I should ask
Bob but you know I haven't uh he's been
busy with his uh telescope projects and
with the Gordon Moore Foundation uh what
do you think he meant by that state well
so I remember when he said that and uh
and to be very clear
um actually said it when we were still
doing that work it wasn't at the time of
the Nobel Prize it was actually at the
time when there were two teams that were
competing uh to make these measurements
it was in a New York Times article yes
uh and in the late 1990s and and you
know what he meant in some ways is
there's a history in not just science
but in all areas of life I think for uh
there to be competition competition can
sometimes Drive Excellence
um it can also Drive I think you've
written about in your book it can drive
people to maybe even make mistakes
um but uh whichever it drives I guess
you can't ignore the fact that it is a
powerful force in people yeah and it
does animate and it could be used you
know in Judaism we have this concept of
the Yates are horror the yatesa heart of
you know the thing that makes you do
good they're good inclination you're bad
in Buddhist tradition there's the Yang
and yang and they have different
elements of each one a synergistic
fashion you mentioned the cosmological
principle and I can't resist because you
know how often do we get together in
person it's been four years since we
just worked in person let alone we do a
podcast together but uh but there have
been claims that maybe the cosmological
principle needs a revision maybe it's
wrong there's a five Sigma tension
according to subie or sarkar who I
mentioned in my book he wasn't super
happy with the way I referred to him but
there's no offense subier I hope you're
watching I hope you'll come on the
podcast at some point but he is claimed
among other things not only is the
cosmological you know principle needing
uh in need of revision or perhaps wrong
but that dark energy is certainly not
the way the consensus has put it that
there is uh the we don't understand dark
energy is is I think the claims that
he's made and he's also made claims
about you know inflation and other
things so you know he has uh but he's an
eminent scientist he's a head of the
theoretical physics Division I think at
Oxford what do you make of these claims
not him specifically obviously the one I
think about the cosmological principle
yeah but the cosmological principle
might need revision based on the
asymmetry of different radio sources
versus the CNB dipole and so I mean I I
can tell you the the evidence or the
data where people have claimed that
there's anisotropy uh of objects in
space
um I found not convincing I'm
particularly familiar with supernovae
and so I don't think there is any good
evidence at least not strong evidence
that uh space is anisotropic
um and so that's important in that I
don't see the evidence for any violation
of the Cosmonaut cosmological principle
you know having said that I mean it's
something you always have to keep in the
back of your mind uh because you know
it's not a principal handed you know in
in you know to us on a silver plate that
says first start with this but you know
when you think about what it means to uh
get rid of the cosmological principle
it's you almost have to go back to the
beginning of like can we do experiments
can we look out in space and infer
things you know when uh when ancients
first looked up at the stars right they
had to figure out uh are those just
holes in the firmament event through the
which light passes are they real
physical objects right and so they did
experiments they looked at uh stars and
over time they noticed gee they collect
together uh that's what would happen if
there was gravity and then they observed
some hey they're moving around each
other okay holes in the firmament
wouldn't do that however some clever
person could come along and say yes but
very creative God or somebody who wants
to mess with us and delicious you know
and so at some point you decide you know
I'm gonna go with the physical
explanation of what I see out there and
the cosmological principle is a lot like
that too I'm going to assume that
there's not a special place in space uh
that everywhere is the same and I can do
experiments now I can learn things in
one location and I can apply them in a
different location and you know that's
such a logical and rational way to
proceed so powerful that you know it's
the last thing I would give up I like I
would be right up there with like oh we
can't do math by the way as we as we try
to explore science you know right we
don't know if math applies out there
either although to be fair you know
there is something that you can have too
much of a good thing and there was a
proposal by Bondi and gold and and
others including the former occupant of
this office Jeffrey Burbage the
quasi-steady state cosmology that Jeff
used to Champion
um I had on giant narlacar who is
hoyle's you know best student uh he's
still doing well and living in uh in
India and we had a great podcast
um but does he still believe steady
state oh yeah oh absolutely okay yeah
and and part of that is just you know he
thinks you can have too much of a good
thing so he not only adds in variants
and Lawrence boost and so forth but time
and variance and that the Universe
should be the perfect cosmological
principle that they invoked was that the
Universe was time translation invariant
therefore it didn't have a singular
origin a singular event
um so so you're right though I think
yeah that would be and that's why I've
gotten interested in these Lorenzen
variants violation tests and things we
hope to do with their we with the
Simon's Observatory and maybe even
optical telescopes on Earth looking for
you know variation in time of flight of
different objects
um and so I want to turn to an article
you were quoted in just yesterday I read
it with uh in physics World maybe and it
was about measuring the Hubble constant
using gravitational time delays and
gravitational lensing can you talk about
lensing another thing that Einstein
predicted he had to recant it I mean he
was wrong he said they would never be
discovered like gravitational waves
Barry barish is uh foreign
my favorite story about about lensing
before uh I stopped interrupting you was
that he um back in the day if you were
Einstein you could write to Nature and
the article starts off with a few a
little while ago a Mr Mandel came to me
asking if I could do a little
calculation and this is published and
then he's like that you'll never see
gravitational lensing so what is lensing
I'm going to tell you about the Hubble
concert
so uh when we look at objects far away
we are looking through a lot of space
and there's often matter in that space
and as Einstein showed a matter bends
light and so uh balls of matter large
groupings of matter connect not just
bending light but since they're Compact
and and uh in one spot they can actually
act like a lens very analogous to a lens
and so what that means is like a lens
you have a rays of light that leave a
distant object and of course the one
that's headed directly at you may go to
you but there are ones that were
diverging they are gonna go away and you
will never see those they're headed off
to other observers
so you know the heavy objects Bend those
rays of light that were headed in
different directions back to the line of
sight of the Observer yes and so you may
see multiple images from those different
rays of light that were headed other
ways you might see as if you have
perfect symmetry of the system where you
have you know that that
ball of matter that's acting like a
lenses directly between you and the
distance object you can get a lot of
rays of light that turn into an actual
ring it's called an Einstein ring and so
these are fascinating objects to study
gravity they're beautiful objects
um and uh because those different Paths
of light that head to us have different
lengths in space uh it takes light
different times to travel from the
object to us and so if the the
background source that you're looking at
actually varies in some way if some
event occurs a supernova or a quasar uh
gulps of matter and changes its
brightness then you may see that event
occur in the different images at
different times and so if you have
uh different path lengths and you
understand the speed of light and you
measure the time differential between
them it gives you information about
distances and anytime you say distances
you know you have the potential to
measure the expansion rate of the
universe because you're measuring you
know you know redshift and you know
distance so that's the great thing about
these these lens systems is they're
great Laboratories for uh Gravity the
the tricky business is you have to have
an understanding of exactly what kind of
matter sorry how it's distributed along
the line of sight
um and you know we don't have perfect
ideas right now of how matters
distributed there's dark matter of
course dark banners and Halos those
Halos have a shape and uh you know we
argue a little bit about what that shape
is so there's a fair bit of what we call
model uncertainty in trying to go from
observations of lensed objects with time
delays to a value of the Hubble constant
so I would say these are very very early
days in playing that game and so it was
a paper reported a week ago
of the first multiply imaged Supernova
uh called refstal where you can measure
uh the different images of the Supernova
and you could try to win for distances
um and I think it's very exciting and
interesting work um but you know looking
at the hardest part by far is the
modeling and so uh as I recall they had
eight or ten different models attempt to
model this if I can use an analogy I
think it's a little bit like hurricane
modeling have you ever seen you know
people try to predict where A
hurricane's going to make landfall and
so you know you're going all right well
let me feed in the wind speed at San
Juan and how fast it was going when it
passed Cuba and then you see these
spaghetti models that predict all these
different places so I would say at this
moment in time the uncertainty is
dominated by the range of models and
what they predict and so I think you
know the the lesson here is that this is
a capability that is being developed and
you know with more objects like this we
will probably learn better how to how to
model these systems just the same way
that you know you like a nice large data
set of hurricanes and actually to know
where they made landfall to to teach
your models so I think that process is
ongoing wow that's excellent
um so you at uh Johns Hopkins and now
we're going to have a little um comic
relief maybe uh from all the nerding out
we've done uh so you are the Bloomberg
professor of physics uh at Johns Hopkins
University yeah um what does the former
mayor of New York uh have to why does he
have an interest in cosmology and
supernovae uh what could he possibly
have first of all what's he like he's
one of the richest human beings have
ever walked the planet yeah what does he
like as a person and can you get him on
the show right so I've been fortunate to
meet him a couple of times and uh I
could tell you I was really surprised I
thought you know this would be somebody
to you know mostly focus on you know
business and philanthropy and uh Ollie
wanted to talk to me about was physics
um you know he was intensely curious he
was well read he wanted to talk about
Quantum entanglement he was interested
in cosmology he wanted to look through
our telescope you know this is what he
was interested in and uh so you know I
was extremely impressed because my you
know well of knowledge is not I think
nearly as vast as his is
um but you know he's quite passionate
about many many different subjects so
you know it also uh uh related to this
is you know he went to Johns Hopkins
University and so you know he's grateful
for the education he received there as
you know many people are grateful for
the educations they received in many
universities and so uh he's given back
quite a lot we talked over dinner last
night about future of education and yeah
well the weather will be replaced by you
know super artificial intelligence are
you nervous are you concerned about your
job security I would yeah that that
would be all right with me okay I'll go
about as far as I can go and then uh hey
I can take over no I mean look I I think
you know the most optimistic take I
could say on this is hopefully
um you know AI will uh do things for us
uh that will leave our minds free to do
you know more challenging things more
interesting things things we're more
curious about or or are more compelling
in some way and so you know I've already
started using chat gbt you know oh write
me a little code for this or you know
write me a draft letter of that or
something like that and so you know it's
it's a it's a tool I mean you know
people I know are quite worried they can
be used in negative ways and I know that
that is the case I think you know it's
hard to think of an advancement in
technology that didn't have this sort of
you know double-edged sword to it like
you know this could be used in wonderful
ways and you know this can be used in
terrible ways right and uh you know ever
since we invented the wheel you know
right that has been possible and
astronomers as past guest Neil deGrasse
Tyson has pointed out you know they're
always intimately connected to War as
accessory to War as uh yeah as anything
people want to do they will use the new
technology for
uh so we'll we'll wrap up pretty shortly
because you have to get ready for your
talk and uh well wait yeah I know I
don't want to like burn out your vocal
cords but you've got such a mellifluous
voice I'm not too worried about that
um the last question I ask about is this
controversy which you because you're so
intelligent you avoid social media like
the plague but on social media this
summer there was a huge yeah brouhaha
the Big Bang never happened proven by
the James Webb Space Telescope but this
also cost a little bit less than 10
billion dollars by the way for my
undergraduates to make that 3D printer
um tell me this this concept yeah that
the Big Bang never happened because we
see objects at Great greater redshift
redshift the record now is 12 or
something like that or 13. 13. it's
insane and change so how is that
compatible how could you possibly have a
big bang unless the Big Bang never
happened and the universe is oh right so
the issue really is as we look further
back with the James Webb Space Telescope
we look to when the universe was very
young when objects were first forming
and we have expectations of what those
objects should look like they should
look like younger versions of what we
see today we have models and
understanding of how they grew to the
size they did how they developed and so
it'd be like you know like saying hey
I've never seen your baby pictures but
let's take a look at them and I expect
you're you're smaller and you're cuter
and stuff like that and you'd be wrong
in my case but but anyway but you know
you have expectations so you know if I
saw a picture of you you're two years
old and you have a full B weird right
I'd go oh this doesn't make sense or
something maybe you weren't born when I
thought you were or something Benjamin
Button right so so you know that's a
kind of an overstatement of the fact
that you know when we've looked out at
distant galaxies some of the earliest
ones astronomers have been surprised
they have looked more massive they have
looked further developed uh than we
thought and so some initial reactions
were oh something's wrong with our
understanding of the big bang and what
we really mean is the time interval that
the Big Bang allows from beginning to
those galaxies only a couple hundred
million years some astronomers are
saying that doesn't seem like enough
time for those to form so there's a
couple things you have to think about to
take a pause with that uh first is this
is hard and so in particular we
recognize that whenever we look out uh
at things we see the rarest of objects
we see the brightest we see the biggest
and so we have to take into account
something we call selection effects you
know you look at it crowd and you see
the tallest people if you think
everybody is that tall you know you're
going to get confused so we have to do
that science carefully and also we've
only looking at a little bit of sky with
the James Webb Space Telescope we
haven't yet done the big wide deep
fields and we're going to get much
better information so I think it's fair
to say the initial look is surprising
things do look more massive and
developed whether that is enough to
break our understanding or tweak our
understanding whether it teaches us
about some processes that occurred
faster than we expected or whether it
actually teaches us something even about
gravity is occurring differently you
know I like to kind of take an open mind
with it let's collect the data you know
if somebody is jumping to the conclusion
that the Big Bang didn't happen then
they probably already had that as their
agenda to to say that at the first
moment of something but you know this is
a beautiful process this discovery
process but it takes time you can't just
take a picture and immediately know what
it means so you know I would tell people
you know check back on this store story
in six months in a year in two years
well no more great so that brings us
beautifully to the final question in the
same article where you're mentioned our
friend uh of astrophysics Roger
Blandford he says
um that he's optimistic that someday
this will wrap up uh one way or another
and he said it's a knowable thing that's
resolution to the hypotension the
universe is cooperative in this sense I
was kind of struck I felt that was a
little bit
um I don't know what the right way yeah
Pollyanna or what you'd say but but I'm
curious what what Adam what you would
say because I don't think Nature's under
any obligation to cooperate with us
whatsoever so what what do you think
first of all are you optimistic as
Rogers so so I would I would answer this
from both an empirical and a theoretical
standpoint so from an empirical
standpoint do I believe that we ought to
be able to measure how fast the universe
is expanding today that we ought to be
able to predict how fast it's expanding
from the customer wave background and we
should expect those two to meet yeah I
think that from an empirical state
standpoint there's nothing in that
measurement process where I say well
that's impossible or nobody can do that
now you know can we make the
measurements better absolutely will the
new facilities teach us things James
Webb ligo future Gaia data releases uh
uh CMP uh experiments that are going to
be extended like S4 Simon's Observatory
these will weigh in on this and teach us
new things but this is a doable problem
that doesn't worry me the theoretical
implications what's actually going on
um
maybe Beyond us it may not be Beyond us
it's hard to predict you know when uh
astronomers notice that the orbit of
mercury was processing right they could
measure that thing all day long they
could say could there be another planet
out there Vulcan that's causing this
we'll look for that and you know
ultimately they didn't find it right but
I'm still holding out hope who could who
can you know who can say well maybe
somebody will come along and develop a
new theory of gravity general relativity
and it will explain this right you
couldn't sit down and say that'll happen
in one year 10 years 100 years 10 000
years or never and so that's the part
that I'm you know not sure if there's
something deep and fundamental going on
and it takes a deep Insight in what time
scale we will have on I just it's very
difficult to predict well speaking of
deep things out of me or deep intellect
has been an inspiration to me for as
long as I've known you uh continues to
be we I learned so much every time I'm
with you I wish you could be out here
permanently we'll talk about that later
uh you know maybe we'll slip another one
of these so that's delicious
I like that yeah uh yeah we have uh we
treat our visitors here nicely
um Adam Reese thank you so much for
visiting fourth time on the podcast I
hope for many many more all right thanks
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]